hey guys i'm duncan 33303 and today i'm
here with a screencast for the mkbhd
youtube channel so i'm going to be
taking a full look at aero weather now
aero weather is a really actually very
handy little tweak for your windows
vista or windows 7 computer that allows
you to go ahead and totally customize
the look of the aero glass based on the
temperature conditions as well as what
whether it's day or night time so once
you download and install arrow weather
and of course the link will be in the
description of this video you can go
ahead and set it up now it's pretty
simple uh the first thing you'll need to
do is set in your us zip code now
unfortunately this is not for
international just yet i do believe that
is actually going to be coming in an
update very soon so actually by the time
you watch this video it might already be
set up but at any rate just go ahead and
put in your zip code you can click
validate give you just a moment to go
ahead and find your area code and your
weather information and then you'll be
all set up now beyond this there are a
couple of options you can go ahead and
actually change the color based on
temperature or conditions i'm leaving at
temperature although conditions probably
would be pretty cool as well
now down here is the color range now
this is kind of important as obviously
depending on where you live the
temperature is going to be different so
for los angeles california you know it's
probably not going to get all that cold
and it's probably not going to get all
that hot right now so i've set it to 30
and 90 is the minimum and maximum of
course depending on where you live you
can go ahead and change it as that will
really dedicate how the colors will
change so it'll actually change quite a
bit more than you know just leaving it
at zero and a hundred or however you had
it set before the last feature is called
night mode and as the name suggests it
goes ahead and changes your aero glass
based on what time it is so about the
time the sun starts going down your all
your air glass will start getting darker
and once it becomes in that daytime it
will go ahead and brighten up so
definitely a very nice little feature so
let me go ahead and show you exactly how
this works so with my current options
you can see that my arrow glass is kind
of a dark green color however let's just
go ahead and change something just
really simply to conditions if i click
that and hit ok you can see here my
arrow glass will kind of turn into a
light pink i can't even tell what that
is but as you can see here it does
change colors based on your different
input now obviously since this is based
off of arrow glass you will need to go
ahead and have either windows vista or
windows 7 for this to work if you're
having problems seeing all the different
colors show up you might want to go
ahead and jump into the arrow glass menu
by just click right clicking click
personalize then come over to window
color and then crank up the color
intensity so as you can see here if you
crank it all the way down you really
can't see much if you like the kind of
you know the totally transparent glass
so i recommend go ahead and put it
somewhere in the middle for the best
effect so that's it i definitely like to
give a big thanks to marcus brownlee for
allowing me to go ahead and put this
video up on his channel and if you're
interested in seeing more from me you
can go ahead and check me out at
youtube.com duncan33303
guys
thanks for watching